en martinique comme ailleurs dès qu'on
n'est pas qu'on n'appartient pas à une
norme forcément danse explose au regard
des autres au jugement et à tout type
d'agression donc ça et là ça n'a pas
changé je suis pas sûr ça changera
demain mais c'est aussi notre rôle de
faire éventuellement lui et les
mentalités et et en ce sens on assiste
aussi on accompagne les personnes lgbt
mais également leur entourage
donc il faut vraiment savoir que si les
familles ont vraiment du mal en tout cas
accepter l'orientation amoureuses de
leur enfant qu'elle n'hésite pas à nous
contacter et on est là aussi pour les
recevoir pour parler avec elle pour les
accompagner dans cette acceptation